la santé maintenant avec les mutations
de la restauration rapide
regardez d'abord ce chiffre il est sans
appel le temps moyen consacré au
déjeuner a été divisé par trois en
trente cinq ans il est passé d'une heure
et demie à un peu plus d'une demi-heure
l'alimentation sur le pouce et notamment
le bon vieux sandwich continue donc de
progresser mais elle veut se débarrasser
cette alimentation rapide de sa mauvaise
image alors quels sont les nouveaux
produits peut-on vraiment manger vite et
bien
enquête nabila taboury nicolas ducron
sorties de bureau une demi-heure
seulement pour déjeuner et un
sempiternel dilemme hamburger ou
sandwich vite avalé pas cher payé
c'est l'idéal quand on est pressé sauf
que les temps changent
le consommateur veut aussi du beau et du
bon ici on me sur les paniers vapeur une
dorade aux aubergines confites ou des
ravioles de royan les fruits et légumes
sont de saison
les viandes acheté en france et ce four
vapeur permet de cuire les plats en
moins de deux minutes
la cuisson vapeur en elle même est déjà
scène c'est à dire qu'en fait elle
nécessite peu de matières grasses
après pour faire bon il vous faut
nécessairement des produits
d'extraordinaires qualités c'est à dire
que chez nous le vrai travail c'est
d'aller en amont chercher chez des
producteurs les meilleurs produits
possibles maison
2 6 euros le plat à 12 euros le menu
elle les clients peuvent consommer sur
place ou emporter leur déjeuner dans le
quartier à 8 euros on a tous un plat et
enfants et encore non votre compte oui
oui dire à plier des pieds en même temps
c'est qu'on est plutôt saine les prisons
pas forcément excessif
on a l'impression de manger léger et ça
le filon santé cet autre enseigne de
restauration rapide à mi lé dessus
côté cuisine le chef est secondé par un
nutritionniste qui traque les calories
pour 100 grammes de canard c'est bien
pour la société pour leur apport en
protéines
c'est bien aux yeux du sandwich un
pot-au-feu de canard frotter salle
plantes vertes esprit design entre
salade au tofu tagliatelles de légumes
les clients ont le choix d'un menu à
moins de 500 calories
aujourd'hui on peut sous prétexte de
produits frais faire exploser les prix
il faut savoir qu'ici le panier moyen et
9 euros 90 et qu'un repas absolument
totalement complet entrée plat dessert
boisson et aux alentours de 13 euros
vite fait bien fait un slogan qui fait
mouche ce qui m'a attiré en priorité
cultivons cette approche bio et éthique
en priorité après ya tout un contexte il
ya le cadre les journaux la rapidité
mais le voile départ c'était vraiment la
présidence label bio diététique dans les
quartiers d'affaires ces nouvelles
enseignes poussent comme des petits
pains et grignote de plus en plus les
parts de marché des sandwicheries